but you know what the thing is
i'm pretty sure a lot of groups ended
ended because of that
what do you mean like people getting in
people's ears yeah
i definitely agree five our beats and
all of this [ __ ]
everybody like there's a lot of women
[ __ ] gass them up
gas em up and be like i'm thinking like
yo
you need to get rid of [ __ ] do you know
but i can guarantee you i can go to any
group any duo
yeah anything like that yeah and there's
always someone like yo you're the
talented one
get rid of this guy his ego's too big
blah blah blah but what do you know
what what what who do you know yeah it
just boggles the mind how people
think they know you out of something
they see
but that's what they call parasocial
relationships yes
yes that's exactly that someone who's
watching really thinks they're really
close to me
yeah people must be like i can tell
you're in turmoil
let me help you look no
i yo i've heard that so but yeah you can
see that
there's the way to the way that their
things are going it's like no it's like
you don't
you're so off things haven't been the
same since abba told priest and afro
and i'm just like [ __ ] yeah they've
been bet they've been like this they
just keep getting better
yes
[ __ ] we
which is why and it's like it's like and
the worst thing is the crazy part is
that they they drop in your dm like
they're whispering yeah
the thing is the thing is the talented
one
[ __ ] why are you hits rich just like
this
you need to leave this [ __ ] cause he's
trying to he's trying to stop
a touch you know what's even funny too
they do this all the time where they
they they talk [ __ ] about the other one
they come to you like it's supposed to
be special
but the thing is [ __ ] i don't know you
yeah i don't make money with you
so whatever the [ __ ] you tell me is
casper the friendly ghost to me
goes right through me right you know the
thing is
this is why i say i never take in
people's compliments
because i also don't take in their like
negatives right there in the middle
right in the middle see
right there in the middle i don't get
too high on you say thank you don't get
too long
they [ __ ] on you you say i understand
move on
ego boosts like yo people really think
this stuff is ego boost it's been the
same since you know me
right all these people talk about oh
you're the best one or
this one man listen we both bring
something and i'm good with it when
season when but that's why people be
guessing
guessing gassing folks up they try to
they try to do that and if you get
caught up in that
you really start thinking you know you
really start thinking
i'm that [ __ ] like yo right and don't
get me wrong it's not that priest can't
stand on his own or i can't we certainly
can't we do
preach has his own career yes in his
whole life you just don't know
the same way i got my own things going
on and it's all i got a whole other [ __ ]
going on you got your own [ __ ] going on
but these [ __ ] they don't know
they don't know it's but it's
crazy how are you gonna be like so
confident about yourself that's what you
talk about a whole [ __ ] that you don't
know about like
you know i know i know i know the
[ __ ] you don't you don't you don't know
the level of this [ __ ]
no no it's just it's just crazy it's
crazy yeah but that's what i'm saying i
think with every group every big group
that's ever come about
there's always people in the ear of
someone guessing
any group you've liked i can promise you
vast majority of the time
there's what do you talk about it's not
him the problem it's the people around
him why
because they got people chattering in
their ears saying like hey nikki you
need to roll solo
when i first received the messages like
that i thought do they these
[ __ ] know something i don't
know
i'm trying to oh
you don't know me oh i am
oh my bad no
no shut the [ __ ] up i don't know
i just ignore all that stuff
but anyways i don't want to get too
[Music]
off-topic
we
[Music]
that